the three most common traits of hyper
successful people the influencer world
wants to be like you have to wake up at
5:00 or you have to do cold plunges or
whatever the right there was actually
very few that they all had in common so
number one was that they had a
superiority complex they thought they
were better than other people and that
they deserved more the second is that
they suffered from massive insecurity
and feeling that they would never be
enough and third they had impulse
control and so you've got this
combination of people who are like I
want to do this big thing so this big
toward thing and they've got this big
away pain that's like I'm never going to
be enough I always have to do more and
then they have impulse control that
keeps them focused on the goal without
seeing the woman in the red dress or
getting pursued by her and that like so
it's like shoot High have a big thing
that that motiv like have a big tower
behind you and stay on the path